das schießen freunde wollen jetzt an
feiern und bei kopf davon
oder endlich mal wieder zwischen freud
wird halo das kind bevor hier allerdings
irgendetwas geht es brauchte meine damen
und herren machen wir uns erstmal das
schmeckt
wir haben vergessen die spülmaschine
anzustellen und jetzt esse ich auf einem
blatt
luca schneider das so dass ich sage ja
den ganzen was sehen aber scheint das
nicht einmal instagram und du machst das
schon
ich glaube an dich luca heute steht
einfach zwischendurch quasi mit mir
selbst in der zukunft weil ich werde das
saargebiet geschnitten haben wir viel
sport spiel selbst allerdings werde
damen und herren wir gerade schlafen
konnte ich habe eigentlich heute morgen
hat das team aufgenommen wo ich
angekündigt habe dass er heute
installieren bildern darstellen hier
stellt sich das werden wir heute
allerdings nicht tun denn wir haben nach
draußen geschaut und das ist die
wirklich wundervolles wetter freuen dass
keine einzige wolke am himmel deswegen
fahren wir bürger helfen
dies macht eigentlich gar keinen sinn
aber wir das macht wirklich garten
seitdem ich in miami zu jeden tag bei
fressen war das von bürgerladen in
amerika habe ich herausgefunden dass es
den auch in essen gibt also 50 minuten
von köln entfernt und da heute ist schön
das wetter ist haben wir uns gedacht
helfer nach essen geht vielleicht im
park und in essen kann man auch gut
essen
es tut mir leid dass dieser blog so
scheiße ist bisher aber jeder blogger
scheiße doch ist es nicht besonders
scheue mich leute ich versuche den blog
jetzt ein wenig aufzupeppen dadurch dass
jetzt eine richtig geile ins heimnetz
einwände
hier aufräumen ich habe alles aufgeräumt
freunden eine kleine rote ich freue mich
von pfarrer es uns wissen
wenn wir uns das essen war erstmal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
menschlich sind ziemlich abstoßend jetzt
der party wird den bürgerpark
ich bin gespannt wir sind gerade zur
falschen seite des parks gelaufen sind
am ausgang und jule du kommst noch nicht
hin wenn paar sekunden später
oder willst du dich mal darzustellen zu
deinen freunden hier carolos älter
das mädchen das macht die ganze zeit
haben die bilder von uns beschweren kann
ich mich da normalerweise eher weniger
wo einfach mal schlecht gelaunt sein und
einen schlechten tag habt oder keine
ahnung was geht einfach mal ein paar mal
durch die blumen am netz durch hinum
zumuten
das habe ich eine chance wir sind zu
pflanzen an denen man riechen soll also
das alter das ist wirklich wahr sind
hier viele bienen habt ihr denn alle
auch ein drittel wir wissen selber
eingebrochene den portugiesen seien war
wie so eine kleine stadt ist sogar
sondern gleich lang und sogar die hat
verspätung new york herausgefunden dass
es eigentlich vier euro eintritt kostet
natürlich gleich noch bezahlen
und ja ich weiß dass die meist
wahrscheinlich auf dieses video geklickt
haben einen zettel steht ihnen die
bürger mit allen zutaten bei five guys
bestellen oder so da kommen wir gleich
zu geben nur leider jetzt auch keine und
judo in der tat und laser luca alter und
laser lokale folgen du hast gehört haben
unser parkhaus unser park ausflug findet
ein ende carola wir können was ich kann
es euch ein vollidiot unterwegs wir
fahren jetzt zu fünf freunde allerdings
ihr habt es schon immer gewesen wir
fahren da nicht normal hin und stellen
uns normalbürger das machen wir
natürlich auch aber wir stellen noch ein
bürger mit allen zutaten also ich bin
gespannt ob der schmecken wird vom
verein der freunde mit allen toppings
ob ich alles drauf kemberger on the way
freunde also ein hamburger mit allen
toppings gestellt also mit zwiebeln
paprika panels und auch scheiße ein paar
sekunden später also freunde
burger vom freistaat
erstmalig auf jeden fall steht mich
richtig rund
also
das ja
wie soll ich den beiden kriegen also wir
haben hier drauf diese zweite thies
tomaten salat
ich bin durch reale toppings einige
anlaufstellen also freunde ich würde
sagen ich weiß jetzt mal rein
[Musik]
eine ewigkeit später pilze
und erst diese ekelhafte age wieso so
drauf die schmeckt aufsicht über alle
respektvollen immer probieren probieren
jetzt mal die bürger freunde also doch
nicht entspannt
ja
dazu gab es carola sich für einen
normalen bürger gestellt
ich finde das geil es beim personal
baker chief bürger
stimmen
normalen bürgern
ich habe vorhin schon normalen burger
gegessen weil ich jetzt über swayzes
bürger mit auch vielen toppings bauen
aber jetzt alle drauf los alamos und
auch pilze paprika alles mögliche was
eigentlich meiner meinung nicht auf den
bürger gehört aber eigentlich geht klar
oder
ich meine jetzt auch keine regel speise
oder so sieht der ganze bürger nur
freunde der ist aber echt
der kamera
kommt aber allein 2
dass mein mund also das recht crazy den
auf jeden fall ein ich habe auf jeden
fall kein hunger mehrere dann geht hier
nur kopiert ja auch gerade mal den
burger die sache ist jule und ich hasse
beide direkt die übrigen über diese
pilze das finde ich echt noch so hart
der bürger zieht
[Musik]
bald aber der bürger sieht an sich
eigentlich recht gut aus oder sonstwo
bei wenig
schmeckt auch für die pzr floridas den
blogger an dieser stelle hier kurz
unterbrechen aber man muss es ja in der
heutigen zeit immer dazu sagen das video
war nichts gesponsert von 530 habe dafür
kein geld bekommen die mir nicht gesagt
mach dass ich hatte einfach nur braucht
mal wieder zufalls zu gehen weil ich
halte mich da relativ häufig frauen die
es immer mega gefeiert habe dann hab ich
halt im internet gesehen hey das gibt es
in essen und frankfurt und essen waren
direkt nebenan werten hunger hatten bock
auf burger ich wollte immer ein video
machen wie ich bei fähigkeit alle
toppings bestellen und das probiere also
ja aber jetzt weiter mit dem blog
aufgegessen bei sky sind wieder da
erstmals statt mir ist echt ein bisschen
schlecht gerade allerdings nicht für
umsetzbar ab nach hause
diesen wieder zurück in köln und was so
völlig unterschätzt wird ist einfach die
andere rheinseite kann man so voll ist
und so und strand hat so einen schönen
ausblick und hier so entspannt in die
steine ins wasser während
[Musik]
endlich wieder zu hause
leute wir sind müde
wir gehen nach einem roadtrip
wahrscheinlich da muss halt heute so
gedacht wir waren einfach unterwegs
carola du und ich sondern weil gesagt
hey kommen wie wäre es wenn wir noch
irgendwie sarah mitten im sommer mit dem
keine ahnung wer doch bockert und uns
einfach immer mehr paare mieten und so
fünf sechs tage
ja wir gehen noch geschlafen während
blog einfach irgendwie und pulli zu
mieten und so wirklich 45 tage
süditalien südfrankreich zu zahlen im
englische zu machen coole aufnahmen für
euch zu machen ich werde natürlich in
der zeit auch locken soll das bisschen
im wald auf jeden fall
das werden wir ein paar tagen hier mal
alles planen und jetzt joghurt ich würde
den block an dieser stelle ist auch wenn
freunde es war ein sehr cooler tag als
er sehr lustiger tag ein sehr
ereignisreicher tag ein sehr
anstrengender tag es war einfach ein tag
lasten like da wenn zeug gefallen haben
wir sehen uns über wochen in einem neuen
blog wieder freunde also seid gespannt
und schreibt mir doch mal bitte in die
kommentare was mögen sie lieber in out
burger oder five guys oder vielleicht
seid ihr auch so und sagt hey ich mag
mcdonald total gerne oder burger king
oder ich gehe lieber zu meinem
restaurant nebenan was bürger machen
also was ist euer lieblings burger
lernen weil er gehen die meinungen krass
auseinander
[Musik]